alors quelles sont les grands projets à
plaisir pour l'année 2023 il y a
plusieurs dossiers en cours notamment le
réaménagement du quartier du valibout en
écoquartier 64 millions d'euros sont
alloués à ce projet Joséphine Coleman
berger où est-ce que ça en est mais
écoutez on a déjà on a déjà commencé pas
mal de choses puisque il y a eu une
démolition importante du silo qui était
un énorme bâtiment qui enclavait le
quartier on a reconstruit une grande
cantine pour l'école Brossolette Louise
Michel et puis Casanova ces trois écoles
qui vont fusionner exactement ça va
devenir un groupe scolaire dédié bien
sûr aux enfants du quartier mais pas
uniquement parce qu'on souhaite
justement qu'il y ait une ouverture et
une mixité sociale on est actuellement
en réflexion justement sur la grande
salle associative que nous devons
bientôt mettre en construction il y a
des réflexions aujourd'hui sur la
reconstruction du centre commercial qui
va être entièrement démolie et
réhabilité
depuis l'installation de la PMI et du
CCAS qui va venir aussi s'installer dans
le quartier donc tout ça c'est en cours
on est on fait pas mal de réunions de
concertation avec les habitants pour
justement les entendre les écouter et
puis bien sûr il y aura toute la
réhabilitation des parkings des espaces
verts puisque ça ça fait exactement
partie tout ça il y a eu 58 personnes
familles qui ont été déménagées d'un
bâtiment qui va être démoli ce qui n'est
pas énorme par rapport à un enrhume
parce qu'en général dans le politique de
la ville dans les quartiers les
démolitions sont bien plus importantes
la majorité des gens iraient reçoit une
famille autrement tout le monde est
parti donc il y aura aussi cette
démolition de de ce bâtiment qui va
permettre aussi de tracer une voix à
l'intérieur du quartier et alors tous
ces changements que vous avez évoqués
vont se mettre en place cette année où
ils vont s'étaler sur plusieurs années
vous avez raison plusieurs années
effectivement oui c'est toujours assez
long je dirais qu'il va falloir huit ans
10 ans pour que tout soit intégralement
terminé bien sûr bien sûr et alors
niveau ur je crois qu'il y a aussi le
centre ville de plaisir qui va aussi
être réaménagé alors quels sont les
changements à prévoir aussi pour en 2023
alors c'est très important parce que
sont quand même 17 hectares qui se
libèrent en centre-ville c'est pas rien
terrain qui appartient à l'hôpital avec
qui nous travaillons en collaboration et
nous allons mettre en place un parc
habité alors nous avons déjà travaillé
tout le diagnostic et également
aujourd'hui la faisabilité de tout cela
toujours avec les habitants moi je suis
incapable de monter un projet sans que
les habitants soit nos partenaires et je
pense que dans l'année qui vient on va
avoir une préparation forte d'une
construction de médiathèque qui va être
certainement le premier je dirais
équipements de ce quartier qui va
devenir un superbe parc avec le Ruau à
l'intérieur qui va on pourra se promener
mais il y aura aussi des habitations
donc j'espère que l'année prochaine on
pourra présenter les plans de cette
médiathèque qui sera le démarrage de
notre centre bourg c'est un objectif à
plaisir de mener la nature avec
l'urbanisme complètement nous avons déjà
54% d'espaces verts sur plaisir nous ne
sommes pas une ville minérale nous
sommes une ville verte et j'ai comme
ambition d'arriver à 60% puisqu'on est
en train effectivement de créer vous lui
disiez des écoquartiers ce centre bourg
qui est à parité mais également des
réaménagements de toutes de toutes les
cours d'école que nous voulons
revégétaliser mais également des des
parcs que nous revalorisons pour arriver
à une ville très verte très très verte
un autre projet qui est en cours qui est
déjà en cours c'est la fusion des
polices municipales des Clayes-sous-Bois
avec plaisir alors pourquoi ce choix
c'est l'union fait la force en quelque
sorte oui vous avez raison c'est cela
hier soir on a fait un conseil municipal
exceptionnel sur les clés et plaisir
concomitamment et on a signé donc cette
convention avec la préfecture et bien on
a besoin effectivement de plus de
policiers municipaux et le fait de se
mettre ensemble dans ces deux communes
qui sont très reliées puisqu'il y a une
porosité nette et évidente par le biais
centre commercial mais pas uniquement et
puis c'est c'était important aussi
d'armer notre police municipale et donc
ce qui fait qu'ensemble je pense qu'on
va être capable dans les années qui
viennent d'avoir 35 policiers municipaux
aujourd'hui nous n'en avons que 20 et on
a vraiment besoin de cela avec les
médiateurs les policiers municipaux et
la police nationale il y a de plus en
plus de communes ivinoise qui fusionnent
avec d'autres communes et qui s'arment
c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui d'avoir une
police municipale armée il y a quelques
années je vous aurais dit non
aujourd'hui on y revient parce que on
entend ces policiers municipaux et bien
le réclamer avoir ce sentiment un peu
d'insécurité et de ne pas pouvoir faire
je dirais un accompagnement vraiment
concret avec la police nationale ça
limite pas du tout au même niveau mais
ça les met je dirais dans une
collaboration beaucoup plus intelligente
et beaucoup plus sécuritaire donc
aujourd'hui c'est presque une obligation
on était presque les derniers à être non
armés donc voilà c'était une décision
bilatérale avec le maire de des
Clayes-sous-Bois qui nous avons une
entente parfaite sur ce montage de ce
syndicat de police et alors quand est-ce
qu'elle sera effective cette police nous
allons démarrer vraiment le travail à
partir de juillet puisque nous espérons
monter en puissance au niveau du nombre
de pollutions entre maintenant et le
mois de juillet parce que aujourd'hui
les policiers sont surtout sur plaisir
et on peut pas sur développer l'emploi
du temps de policiers Plaisirois pour
aller en plus sur les clés donc nous
attendons d'avoir des policiers
supplémentaires pour pouvoir
redistribuer le travail et puis à terme
je dirais avoir quelque chose qui ne
réfléchira que sur un seul territoire
qui sera les deux communes côté santé
les travaux de la future Maison Médicale
devrait commencer en début d'année alors
quels seront les services apportés au
plaisir roi alors déjà c'est je tiens à
lire c'est une maison médicale qui est
entièrement prise en charge par le
département des Yvelines il faut le dire
la ville de Plaisir
n'y met pas un centime donc c'est c'est
important il y aura la capacité
d'accueillir pas mal de le médecin et
d'infirmiers et puis de paramédicaux à
l'intérieur il y a une il y a un
potentiel à peu près une quinzaine de
possibilités d'accueil alors aujourd'hui
nous avons une cellule qui s'appelle la
ruche qui est à l'intérieur de l'hôpital
dans lesquels il y a déjà deux médecins
et puis différentes une infirmière
également qui sont déjà là et qui
attendent cette création et nous en
parallèle on a mis en place un agent sur
la ville qui est dédié complètement à la
recherche médicale enfin des médecins
potentiels qui devraient rentrer dans
cette maison médicale puis vous savez
qu'un plaisir on a aussi développé une
aide de 10000 euros à chaque médecin qui
vient s'installer sur notre territoire
dans le contexte de la désertification
médicale exactement et puis surtout vous
savez je dis toujours il y a quelques
années si des mers c'était occupé de la
santé en nous aurait dit mais de quoi
vous mêlez-vous madame et aujourd'hui on
trouve tout à fait normal que les mères
apportent je dirais quelque chose de
positif et c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en
place aussi une télécabine qui
fonctionne très très bien
bien on vient pour la bobologie bien sûr
mais on est en direct avec un médecin
donc voilà cette maison médicale on
l'attend avec impatience on la présenter
au Conseil municipal et dans le journal
ça va être un très très beau bâtiment et
j'espère avec beaucoup de médecins à
l'intérieur oui vous cherchez encore des
médecins et bien sûr oui sur les trois
années enfin dire deux ans et demi de
mise en place du bâtiment oui on va bien
sûr en chercher davantage bien alors la
cause des femmes vous touche également
beaucoup l'année dernière de bâtiments
ont été inaugurés la maison Calypso et
le café des femmes qui étaient tout
dernièrement le 9 décembre la maison
Calypso c'est une maison d'écoute pour
les femmes victimes de violences
sexuelles et conjugales il s'agit de la
première dans le département c'est une
fierté oui rien que d'en parler j'en ai
la chair de poule je suis désolé mais je
suis très très émue partout c'est toutes
ces démarches que nous pouvons faire
auprès des femmes qui ont des vrais
difficultés des difficultés de violence
mais également des difficultés je dirais
de méconnaissance de pas mal de choses
par rapport à leur corps et c'est très
important de pouvoir les accueillir et
quand on a pu en tant que président du
conseil de surveillance de l'hôpital de
plaisir quand on a pu avec et grâce
aussi au département des Yvelines ouvrir
cette maison à l'instant dans l'enceinte
de l'hôpital aujourd'hui j'étais
vraiment très très touchée et je sais
que on a déjà des centaines de femmes
qui sont venues et il faut savoir que
l'année prochaine va commencer aussi
vont commencer les travaux dans la
maison définitive Calypso qui est une
maison beaucoup plus grande dans un parc
qui est un plaisir aussi et que le
département va complètement réaménager
pour ces femmes et le la maison va
s'agrandir
ça va être sublime parce qu'il y aura un
accueil médical des coûts psychologiques
il y a de l'art thérapie les femmes
peuvent venir autant qu'elles veulent
vraiment ça vaut la peine d'aller voir
rien que les personnes qui sont là et
qui accueillent ces femmes c'est une
émotion énorme de voir cette empathie
cette ouverture d'esprit alors l'autre
initiative c'est le café femme une
inauguré en décembre dernier il
accueille des femmes en situation de
vulnérabilité sociale et les
accompagnent sur le chemin de l'emploi
est-ce que vous savez à peu près le
nombre de femmes qui l'a accompagné
depuis le 9 décembre il y en a une
quinzaine il y a 15 femmes qui
travaillent avec
avec le nôtre la société Lenôtre comme
vous le savez qui est installée à
plaisir et avec L'Oréal également
pourquoi L'Oréal mais pour leur redonner
confiance en elle par rapport à leur
apparence et puis le nôtre parce que le
nôtre est bien leur donne des formations
boulangeries pâtisserie et elles vont
vraiment aller vers l'emploi et ces
femmes sont encadrées par l'association
banlieue santé et quand on a fait quand
on a fait l'inauguration des femmes de
Marseille sont venus
pour démontrer déjà ce qu'elles avaient
fait à Marseille à son nu jusqu'à
plaisir là aussi ça a été un moment
c'était une transmission et puis je
remercie bien sûr ces deux entreprises
qui accompagnent et qui font pas du tout
de la communication mais vraiment un
travail concret sur le sujet et puis on
a le mamobus qui vient régulièrement à
plaisir aussi pour justement accompagner
les femmes pour les mammographies donc
tout ce qui tourne autour de la femme
j'avoue que dès qu'il y a une
possibilité de faire quelque chose je
suis là on le sait alors pour revenir
sur sur le café des femmes comment doux
est venue cette initiative alors
l'initiative et ben je suis allée
rencontrer le directeur le président
directeur général le nôtre qui m'avait
demandé d'aller le voir parce qu'il
avait un projet et donc c'est lui qui
m'a l'étincelle vient de là et il m'a
évoqué ça il fallait qu'on trouve un
appartement pour la ménager et il
fallait qu'on trouve bien sûr les
encadrants et puis les femmes aussi qui
étaient intéressées et comme nous nous
avons une vraie démarche proactive au
niveau du valibout avec nos médiateurs
et puis je suis très proche des femmes
puisqu'on avait créé aussi des marches
au niveau de du valibout pour voir ce
qui allait ce qui n'allait pas avec nos
gilets roses ce sont les femmes du
valibout qui s'étaient engagé là-dedans
et bien on avait tout ce qu'il fallait
on a trouvé avec le bailleur
l'appartement qui a été refait
intégralement grâce à une architecte
l'appartement est splendide chez Yves
volontiers y habiter c'est vraiment très
très bon ça a été super sublimement fait
il y a une cuisine il y a un petit salon
de travail enfin c'est vraiment très
très joli et puis pardon et ensuite et
bien banlieue santé est arrivée pour
encadrer c'est ouverte tous les jours
c'est pas uniquement ouvert aux femmes
qui font cette formation c'est ouvert
aux femmes qui veulent venir boire un
café discuter et c'est un endroit
vraiment fabuleux vraiment fabuleux je
vous invite à y aller si vous avez le
temps un jour et bien l'invitation est
prise et donc juste avant de terminer
cet entretien Joséphine colmarger on va
passer à l'interview express
[Musique]
alors le principe cinq questions courtes
et 5 réponses courtes nous poserons les
mêmes à tous les mers de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est-ce que
vous êtes prêtes
allez vous augmenter les impôts locaux
dans votre commune
on n'a pas le droit à dire peut-être
vous avez une le droit de réflexion
actuellement le budget est au mois de
mars effectivement j'ai des rencontres à
faire avec les plaisirs royales il y a
des choses à dire pour ou contre la
limitation à 30 km heure dans la ville
je suis assez pour je suis assez pour ou
contre l'obligation du bio dans les
cantines
pour mais c'est très cher on en a déjà
pardon
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions
avez-vous déjà eu peur physiquement oui
êtes-vous une mère heureuse oui ça se
voit je crois et bien merci beaucoup
José c'est la fin de ces questions
courtes réponse courte je le rappelle
vous êtes la mère de plaisir merci
beaucoup